[Applause]
[Music]
okay now we're back here on overtime and
let's get the questions from the
internet for Andrew Ross Sorkin do you
think we would have as many economic
problems if we had just nationalized the
banks ooh there are some socialism we
nationalize the banks some people were
for it at the time remember yeah no I've
been nationalized the banks I think we
would have had as many problems it's not
more ultimately maybe in the short term
we would have had less problems but
we're look look at the amount of debt we
have now look at what it would it would
have cost ultimately to nationalize the
banks I think we probably would have had
today we probably be in a better place
I'm thinking long-term we would have had
a disaster in our hand and I can't
imagine a country that wouldn't allow a
public option would nationalize the
banks I mean but by the way we've
already deep our banks are so big and so
too big to fail we've we've de facto
nationalism anyways I like that thank
you but it's true though we've
nationally we've nationalized him anyway
even though we pretend we haven't all
right Paul Begala for those who don't
know please explain your Gilligan's
Island analogy of the Romney versus
llama debate yeah it did I did come from
Newsweek where I said now we're we're
down to Thurston Howell the third versus
the professor which is what it is and
who's gonna get us off the island
I would I would go with the professor
late if I have powers you know he almost
had that plane working never they they
built out of straw charles murray hasn't
the universal reward system of every
child getting a gold star every day in
order to instill self-worth resulted in
a false sense of self-importance that
has negatively affected our society well
I was on that page 20 years
we carry on that right I mean that you
know the self-esteem thing did we give
you a short chair you look shorter there
if we give you a bad chair you know
I shoot you I thought there's a Greek
now the self-esteem movement is pretty
much down the tubes among people who
look at the Sun in it we know for a fact
that we have kids who have the highest
self esteem in such things as their math
ability and the lost math scores as you
know the Koreans have terrible
self-esteem with regard to their math
but they get really high scores right
and we were talking about college before
in the panel I think in 1960 something
like 15 percent of kids earned an A in
prior colleges and now it's something
like 43 percent yeah I know of there's
one professor at Harvard Harvey
Mansfield who now gives two grades the
real grade and then the Grady puts in a
transcript because if you show up with a
B you aren't going to get into Yale Law
School or something it's ridiculous
right it looks like we're just like a
college diploma is just a consumer
product that you saw something we can
agree on bill I think that I think the
BA I think the PA is to working together
okay se cop do you believe the
Republican budget meets moral criteria
ooh there's a broad question I think it
attempts to and actually Paul Ryan talks
about this a lot just in little known
circles he wrote a great essay for a
publication called our Sunday visitor
it's a Catholic publication in which he
talks about economic decisions having
moral consequences and then moral
decisions having economic consequences
and I think that's something that
Republicans especially need to point out
more than they do the rhetoric goes that
you're either a fiscal conservative or a
social conservative and the two don't
often meet and I think conservatives
need to point out that you can exist as
both and in fact we have to exist if
both we can't eliminate or ignore or one
of the other why did he throw an R and
under the bus who Paul Ryan what do you
mean he today George today through you
know he used to say but this is why I'm
in politics I hand out the book to
everyone who works for me and ran you
know now he's throwing her under the bus
oh I don't know why as an atheist
because she was an atheist oh well I
just I just think the winds are shifting
he was getting he went to George Hannah
Catholic
school and a lot of Catholics protesting
I saw that right and so a part of what
they were protesting is that he does he
has said that he bases a lot of his
philosophy on unread and so today he
disavowed her and said no that because
cited her atheism particularly yeah
that's what I would imagine but it
didn't bother him all the years before
he because he like the parties or
apology I'm sure he likes you like he
likes her [ __ ] everybody policy just not
right theism all right
that's Paul someone has a black night
asked why do the Democrats always seem
to lose the message war it's a good
point I think because of my Devon not
always not always but very often we're
afraid to take our own side in a fight
you know we sit there for going it's
such a good point and you know look
that's why I come in on your show cuz
you don't do that I don't do that I
actually leave in these things I don't
wanna fight for him but that's a very
good point even too much nuanced mean
anything about too much knew you watch
news I'm not always nuanced yeah
Republicans never nuanced right it's
true and inside that's what I love it
with fundamental truth that's what I
love about and I wanted to ask this on
the show tonight but we were Trent at a
time that's what I love about Joe Biden
saying as a motto for the Democrats
running in this election GM is alive and
bin Laden is dead and pointing out that
if the situation was reversed because we
have the quotes from Mitt Romney saying
he would not have gone into sovereign
Pakistan to go after bin Laden and we
know what he said about GM that's on
record - so if Mitt Romney was president
actually would be the reverse GM would
be dead and bin Laden would be alone
you think that's true you think that's
true lady lady dick why'd you look girl
I cannot defend him on that I can't I
didn't defend him on the the car thing I
didn't defend him Kansan I will not all
right s Proctor s in light of the recent
Secret Service Tech scandal isn't it
time for the country to have a serious
debate about legalizing prostitution out
of the country was a said at least
outside of the country I thought that
was her I thought it was already legal
it was anything and you know what I must
say uh kudos to the Colombian police or
whoever when the when the hooker went to
them and said you know this guy's trying
to [ __ ] me and you know that looks bad I
mean 800 well it does I mean 80 down to
800 down to 30 I mean that's just what
an [ __ ] what did he pass so true what
we can all agree Democrat Republican
independent yeah he's just a fiscal
conservative but in for that muff thank
you I did I'm not gonna be money for
that mom no um but in a lot of countries
if a hooker came to the police station
it said I've been robbed do to get out
of here you know that and they treated
her with dignity this is your job and
you know you know better then she's not
you know she's an escort she is like a
fine
rum oh she's fine we saw the picture
cannot treat her like some common that's
right another uh uh oh no you uh and
that's all the questions I had can't be
very much everybody thank you
[Music]
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests your questions right after
the show at HBO calm